je trouve que mettre des gens à la rue
sans relogement c'est inadmissible dans
une société comme la nôtre est encore
plus en crise sanitaire
[Musique]
on a des gens qui n'étaient pas qu'ils
n'étaient pas touchés jusqu'à présent
qui était on va dire en tout cas
préserver du manque alimentaire de la
difficulté de loyer etc et qui se
retrouvent depuis la crise sanitaire
avec déconfinement avec du chômage
partiel subi etc se retrouvent dans des
difficultés financières doivent faire
des choix on va dire cornélien entre se
nourrir ou ceux où se loger
on a plus des personnes quand même qui
au niveau des ressources
c'est des petites ressources entre 700
mille euros elle essaye de de continuer
à payer le loyer mais au détriment des
fois d'autres choses
on
[Musique]